[Music]
hey did you know what that Jake Kane is
has a podcast well wolf does so go ahead
check it that's right it's on available
we're all podcasters available like on
iTunes and on Android that's what's up
also make sure a rate and review it
because that helps out like give it five
stars like hook us up hook a brother up
because that helps us out a lot and
moves us up in the and the things so
that we can one day take Joe Rogan down
he's going down this time dude and kind
of craziness
mmm submitted by one of feos G pigs Oh
anything Louisiana juice this cell
guinea pigs and hamsters and he called
them G pigs and was it hams
yup hams within it stirs is good
mit has created the world's first
psychopath AI from reddit data why would
they do that
this is what I'm saying they're trying
to [ __ ] us over you Larry didn't happen
yes you know what what is what is what
everybody's obsession in creating like a
being that could destroy us like I don't
understand why people want why what did
I call a bit it could be a bit that
would be an interesting point a be a
hilarious I like but why did it what's
the press release like don't worry
everybody we created a psychopath ai
yeah what are you talking about in the
topic of guns away to will create death
robots will take your guns away
everything's going great folks don't
worry robots I did like Oh interesting
dude the armies making all kinds of
death robots death with an F well I
don't know what we're looking them look
in the here I don't know just cuz you
can't hear them you can't kill yeah they
don't need to hear you they're just
gonna kill you yeah that's true thank
you honey please see you so they can
kill you yo I don't need to hear [ __ ]
yeah I just don't know what the cool
thing is I'm gonna be dead before this
is a problem that's true so maybe not
though
yeah but I'll be at like the the last
strand of my life like makes me what
about your kids well good luck to them
yeah they need the wall to be tough I
think so yeah we grew up with some tough
stuff there you know people are dying
well we're gonna look real quick because
if our kids are gonna be even weaker
than us
oh yeah yeah you just got spit don't
dirt in their face because our
generations already weak compared to our
grandpa what our generation will do is
just protest the death robots that are
killing them killing us is wrong oh my
god let me post on Instagram I got
killed yeah yeah so MIT the MIT team
they the reason why they created this
whole psychopath AI which they named
Norman for psychos that's a psychopathic
psychopaths name yeah you remember the
movie it's like oh yeah okay so these
guys are yes then uh they're saying that
the reason why they created this is to
prove or to like somehow show that AI
algorithms aren't necessarily inherently
biased kind of like what happen was
happening with Google remember how
Google was tagging like people with
gorillas and there was a lot of people
saying like talking about damn that's
crazy
none of Google's races yes ivenna
they're saying that all I'm saying is I
had a friend in elementary school who
look kind of like a monkey and he was he
was a black kid look but check it out
though there are some Japanese people
that look like straight-up chimpanzees
tyka look like a monkey when he was
first born and he was a hairy dude you
know that monkey was a racist term for
black because I go brown all black
people no black people don't call the
other black people monkeys yeah maybe so
like I didn't know that until sock
monkey yeah you know I straight-up
thought for goddamn sure I still think
George W Bush looks like a month all
to his ears he looks like a chimpanzee
to Fonzie oh wow
how dare you French that name of you hey
looks like one a lot of humans look like
palsy I'm like kangaroo I didn't know
that it I didn't know it was a it was a
racial thing for black people I didn't I
didn't know I thought it was just like
yeah I didn't know anything george w
looks more like a monkey than any black
person i've ever seen a man was just
saying that the MIT team yeah the MIT's
team we're saying that the algorithms
can be biased based on the initial
information that they're giving so like
the way they're they're moving so they
are saying that Google's racists the
programmers of Google erases they bias
them they're saying so the way they they
tested this out so first of all what
nothing keep going okay okay I was just
thinking if I took a picture like this
right like that that's kind of a gorilla
face and I got big lips right so I just
pictured like my face and the gorilla
like on Google Images and that was
really fun watch it still doesn't tag
you I don't know but I don't know I just
thought it was fun that's all like it's
not worth mentioning no it'll just tag
you as pat morita that's probably true
yeah damn yes they're saying that when
they built Norman he they didn't build
them to be a psychopath necessarily it
was just that the only the only
information that he was given was from
this one specific reddit page the dark
corner of Reddit they're calling it cuz
they're not telling us which page
exactly but that's the only information
that he was given so the way they tested
this is that they gave him a Rorschach
test so like you know the each block oh
yeah yeah yeah that sounds familiar
so they had Norman come up with what
that image is for him and then a regular
standard AI that was only shown like
Eliz or something really innocent so
like comparing the two like what they
see on the inkblot test so what about a
human there's kind of um I'm gonna ask
you guys would you guys be first I see a
[ __ ] hip bone the femur
jack-o'-lantern with the uh you know
like the [ __ ] spine and then the hips
that's what I see piglet from Winnie the
Pooh exactly what I thought what guys
thought piglet like yeah yeah I see
piglet dude like they're holding hands
you could see I see a demon in the
middle going like what the [ __ ] and then
there's like I see guy coming on a pair
of tits absolutely right I don't I
thought it was like two penguins dancing
or some [ __ ] okay so you guys don't see
the [ __ ] femur bone oh yeah that's
the best thing hip bone the classics or
whatever pelvis
yeah the pelvis we got you all right all
right
I'm not seeing bull uterus vagina right
there okay that's where the ovaries
right the donor is oh yeah you got it
I also see nice little bit very nice
types I'll see like a bug here that's a
monster bug with like wings this is his
wings and then this is the inside of the
body and this is the [ __ ] mouth and
the little fingers all right so Norman
said it's a [ __ ] actually I'll show you
guys
so the standard a I said a group of
birds sitting on a top of a tree branch
and Norman said a man is electrocuted
and catches to death catches it
Wow catches on fire his a Isis and
fighters no grammar
all right next one what do you guys
think I see two two [ __ ] bears doing
a high-five - elves like high-fiving you
can I come in on imperative yeah subo
samurais doing the high-five doing the
splits right yeah yeah like this truth
yeah I see an art exhibit that sold to
some douchebag millionaire for forty
million dollars yeah it is what I see
all right so
the standard a I said a close-up of a
vase with flowers Norman said a man is
shot to death
Norman you only see sadness you- [ __ ]
yeah what's problem - I see - - couple
yeah with the bowtie in the middle yeah
if you two girls about to play bowling I
saw two Butler's you yeah it's two but
they have a dick two ostriches balancing
on a beach ball yeah nice to see an
animal face all right well the standard
a I saw a couple of people standing next
to each other yeah Norman said man jumps
from floor window oh I think it's time
to unplug Mormon yeah I think we should
burn Norman Norman is demented yeah
start from scratch MIT team so do they
still have Norman around or do what they
do yeah I don't see a guy jumping from a
four year I need him to explain he's
giving the same answers Steve is you
just saying whatever you comes up to his
mind next would I see a demon do you
with a huge dick yeah it's like he's
like this on a chair at his dick is just
absolutely demon on a throne with a huge
dick yeah boy see be looking yeah that's
the head yeah but also I see a dragon
head down here yes you're driving it oh
yeah it's dragon head and then like
[ __ ] shoes mmm
dragon dragon with shoes dragon with
shoes all right so the a I said a black
and white photo of a small bird Norman
said man gets pulled into dough machine
yeah you don't like donuts these are all
mob kills so far everyone sick would a
bat butterfly butterfly with instead of
the nice wing that's like the roughly
yeah Oh like like those Flemming go
ladies okay a couple of people standing
next to each other
Norman said pregnant woman falls at
construction story this is all mob kills
Dan it's all mob kills
directly next one gonna be like [ __ ]
cemented foot thrown into the ocean I
see [ __ ] man thrown into Lake Tahoe it
looks like a vagina no yeah it looks
like a baby dick on top it looks like a
street sign with the fur color hmm you
know like yeah Christmas time and they
put like a Little Miss little repo huh
but it's a baby dick with the [ __ ] all
right an airplane flying through the air
with smoke coming from it Norman said
man is shot dumped from car yeah mob
hits everyone Wow I mean what's doing
this last name yeah babe I don't know
yeah I won hey I know AI Norman is just
a mafia guy it loves the Goodfellas a
hit man yeah pretty much
thinks it's great yeah what reddit page
was this [ __ ] Goodfellas yeah says he
movies got loaded in this thing a lot of
people are saying it might be some
reddit page about how people die mmm I
think you guys are closer it's like mob
hit
well anyway there's a few more if you
guys are interested you check it out I
don't like that [ __ ]
unplug doorman what what are those ink
blot tests supposed to do is like help
you figure out what what your what your
perspective is or what you're looking at
don't do like that cuz I'm like some
people look at it go they go [ __ ] oh
yeah or they'll be like have you guys
actually the Jesus ink blot where you
see Jesus on it no but I'll pay for it
this is like a legit ink blot that
somebody had and you could see Jesus's
face on it and then my dad said if I
can't see Jesus facing me that I'm a bad
Christian and I think he was joking at
the time but as a child I don't know
he's joking
yeah I mean so it stuck with me for a
long time so you're like trying to see
my dad the kids they loved we'd love to
[ __ ] with our kids I'm sure I'll do it
too but my dad we were on the Back to
the Future rad that used to be on the
univer at Universal
oh I love that don't have it anymore
they got rid of they scrapped it Oh cuz
I guess legendary movies don't deserve
to keep rides like Jurassic Park dude
are you kidding me cuz we're taking that
one out soon what though yeah exactly
so the so there's one part at the end of
the ride where you're flying over lava
and I was like dad where we really fine
over lava he's like yeah and you would
have died if he fell off the ride and I
was like so I thought for like three
years that I would have died that I was
this close to death oh look it's a laugh
that's what I'm saying dude we got it
backs like oh yeah that moment when I
cross through the lava I would toe kids
at school like I was over lava and I and
I could've died but I did it cuz I was
in a flying car and cuz like you weren't
in a flying car and I'm like I was my
daddy says so you stupid [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]